check check Jews
Jews
Jewish people is it public just funny
like an alt-right podcast and write
soundtracks you know they're like white
people
white people Jews
is it popping when I say Jewish people
people
um that's a bit
we're doing about with an alt-right
podcast who's doing a soundtrack
uh welcome to the Tim Dylan show thank
you very much for listening for watching
for consuming
for digesting this content thanks to
those two dudes Harry and Chris that
came on for our little bonus episode we
had fun we had so much fun hanging out
with them they're awesome [__] dudes
they do trigger a lot of people that
supposedly can't be triggered it's the
right-wing people got so mad and they're
young they're in their early 20s and
they're yelling about Biden and they do
it in a cringy way but that's the point
that's the whole point look at all the
attention that you're giving them and
they're actually off you know when
they're not going like Biden's you know
Biden's coming [__] which is what
they do which I get
um they're awesome dudes and now we're
all uh friends so uh
you know and no one's happy about it I'm
sure like their people are not happy
about it and my people might not love it
but and everyone's like oh you destroyed
them I'm like we had an argument I don't
think they were destroyed there's people
that will agree with them there's people
that'll agree with me am I a better
talker yeah I'm [__] 38 and I get
paid millions of dollars every year to
talk I hope I'm better than a 20 year
old tick tocker that doesn't mean I'm
right I'm right for other reasons that's
the thing about debates debates aren't
who's right or wrong it's who can talk
and I can talk
but awesome dudes and respect the hell
out of them for coming on the show and
you know really cool and I'm gonna I'll
make a tick tock with them when I'm when
we're
in the same area but let's talk now
about this wga strike it is directly
affecting me these are the issues I care
about these are the issues
I have deals in this town now because I
got something going on I got something
going on now for the first time in years
and uh people are we were excited about
projects and these projects have they've
grinded to a halt
because of the wga The Writer's Guild of
America and I support them I'm at full
solidarity with them however
I do have to maybe try to negotiate
something because I don't have faith
that the people doing this are going to
be able to do it
so I have to do it
um The Writer's Guild is angry
because they're not they're not making
the money they want to make
and the streamers
Netflix
Amazon
Paramount Hulu
Disney Fox
and others
they have the money and the writers go
we want more of the money
so
here is the demands of the writing now I
this is the way I look at the strike
number one
there's not a ton of great entertainment
on TV right now or in the streamers
right now there's not a there's not an
amazing amount
right there's not a lot of it that's
great
now so you know
that's that's something that we all have
to acknowledge too during this strike we
are in a recession
Disney just laid off 7 000 jobs IBM's
laying off jobs ai's taking over a lot
of people's jobs a lot
and the show and people go but
can AI write La Brea the show about the
whole that opened in Los Angeles where
people fall through it and are they end
up somewhere else could AI do that and
the answer is perhaps
the answer is could AI could artificial
intelligence write the show uh La Brea
about people falling through a hole into
a different world and then falling in
love and getting angry at each other
could that happen perhaps I don't know
I don't know
what we are seeing now
is a
you know AI has now become real Chachi
BT is real the idea of this is not as
far off as it once was this is actually
something that you could imagine writing
shows so this
is what they want the pattern of Demands
is a constitutionally required statement
of General objectives these are the
general objectives
increase minimum compensation
significantly to address the devaluation
of writing in all areas of Television
New Media and features
no
we can't do that not one we can't do
that's I'm speaking now for I'm speaking
now
because I know because these are my
friends and billionaires I'm speaking
now for them because I wear the glasses
that they wear do you understand do you
have a furry Polo thing that's 3x
and it was bought in a bin they're nice
I'm going to tell you what we can do and
what we cannot do
this doesn't mean I'm I'm I'm the person
who's representing the billionaires but
I'm for the writers
so it's easy to get confused here
I'm in solidarity with the the
Communists that don't want to work
I'm kidding it's a comedy podcast I'm in
solidarity with writers but I'm
representing the billionaires in this
exercise to help everybody come to the
table do you understand yes or yes you
get it right I want the writers to win
even though many of them have called me
a Nazi on Twitter I want the writers to
win but I'm also representing the
billionaires first first event increased
minimum compensation significantly that
cannot know
that is not going to happen I understand
why you would want that
we are not going to do that
standardized compensation and residual
terms for features whether released
theatrically or on streaming this is an
interesting one also no
also no because we can't
if it's on streaming or if it's in the
feature it's different
it's we don't know what's going how
it'll all play out so what we need to do
is not establish any type of uniform
standard about how much money you should
get paid address the abuses of many
rooms now I like this we can do this put
them now many rooms mean tiny little
rooms of tiny writers and they're abused
because they're small and they put them
in a small place and nobody likes that
we can do a larger room for them and I
think that's we can put in the contract
right now many rooms become major rooms
or Mega rooms
will take five or six Riders and we'll
put them in a very large room and let
them do what they want but
we we cannot pay them anymore ensure
appropriate television series writing
compensation throughout the entire
process of pre-production production and
post-production meaning from the from
the pilot
to the to the you know oh we're gearing
up to do it to the actual doing of it to
so this is it's kind of like when you
think about abortion with the chart and
you go you know 15 weeks and this and
that and you know post-production is
like late term abortion
here's what I think about this
I think
we can
we can make sure in short appropriate
television series writing compensation
throughout the entire process
we can't do it for the entire process
from the people that I've spoken to
we can do it for a week
any week you want and I think this is a
good thing whether it's pre-production
post-production
actual production
we will for one week during the
production
make sure you're appropriately
compensated for one week during the
process
any the week is up to you
but if it takes
17 weeks or something to get something
happening it's we can't one week we'll
do it expand span protections to cover
all television writers I don't know what
that is and I so we're not doing it
apply MBA minimums to Comedy variety
programs made for New Media like
should a show on Snapchat about two
people that are dating despite one of
them not having a face
because they're on Snapchat you've seen
these shows where the person's face
caves in but they have a wife and
they're in India
I think that's what this is talking
about I don't know what I imagine this
is talking about is that's a new uh type
of uh New Media Snapchat and that's just
comedy variety show now some sick [__]
will find it funny but it's really a
variety program it's like it'll be a man
who's like a snake it's like he has no
bones and he's a snake with a head but
he has a kind of a regular looking wife
she ain't great but those are the shows
on Snapchat one of them is called Born
different and it's like somebody who's
just goes I don't have a nervous system
but I'm here and this is my wife
and they're saying should people get
paid to write those I don't know
but maybe I kind of enjoy them sometimes
so maybe we'll give them money for that
increased residuals for under
compensated reuse markets like when it's
you know the thing is we're gonna use it
again
no
uh pension plan and health fund
increased contributions to pension plan
and health fund
here's the thing
no but because too many of them smoke
cigarettes
too many writers I see in the Silver
Lake the Echo Park area are always
smoking cigarettes outside of a cafe
I don't think we can increase the
contributions to the health plan
for future contracts okay some of this
is boring
we gotta do something here where we're
like let's
like we're not getting rid of chat GPT
you're not getting rid of AI like a lot
of people are going we want no AI that's
what they want right no AI That's not
realistic we can do no people from the
Netherlands
like no
Dutch people in a writer's room
we can exclude races of people much
easier than we can exclude
artificial intelligence because that's
just the that's the new game in town but
we could say like no Eastern Europeans
because they creep everyone out that's
fair
let's negotiate along those terms
now
what are the top shows on TV right now
this is how we're going to make this
decision because sag is going to strike
the union I'm a member of I'm the Screen
Actors Guild I'm an actor on the screen
like unlike many of you
I'm an actor on the screen and I'm and
I'm uh participating in uh
in many of different projects right now
um
so I don't know I'm just saying
I'm looking at these shows and this is
what that beef with the Ali Wong she's
done well huh why don't I have more
Asian fans to be honest
all I do is talk about China how much I
love China my Chinese godson and you
know Matt Rife they're saying has all
these Asian fans
this is what I'm being told is Matt Rife
now is huge in China and I'm nowhere
I I'm not I like Matt Rife but does he
know who president Z is
I do nothing but advocate for Z
and I have nothing
no Asians come very few Asians one Asian
fan to me is worth a thousand whites
true so if you come to my show
and your Asian man I am I'm I'm happier
than you'll ever know well I hope the
writer's trike is okay I don't know
what's gonna happen but I I'm just
saying that it's going to be it's going
to be pretty difficult to get everybody
to the table because I think when the
writers have a good point these
streamers are making a lot of money
let's see what all of these people make
because the writers keep focusing on the
CEOs of these companies like David
zazlov and uh Ted surrandos hit Netflix
shout out to Ted my specials on there
I'm not even talking to these hoes Ted
but
you know everybody is like
you know what's the average salary of a
TV writer in America 62 000 a year
that's the average yeah
that's not great
but I know a lot of them that make a lot
more but I I understand what they mean
they want more money
it's fair now go to there's a chart here
that'll show you what all the CEOs of
the streamers make you can easily find
it because
that's what these writers are saying
they're like why should this guy who's
running Warner Brothers make more than
me
I'm the fourth writer on Abbott
Elementary
why should the guy who runs Warner
Brothers make more money than me I wrote
on a failed pilot three years ago about
uh a gym teacher
um who discovered uh uh square dancing
and got all the kids to square dance and
Hulu bought it but it didn't work and I
don't know why I don't also have a yacht
our Emmanuel CEO of endeavor 308 million
David zazlov Discovery CEO and this is
what they all made last year 246 million
Bob Iger 45 million Bob trade pack
Disney 32 million igers Disney as well
Murdoch 31 million at Fox Reed Hastings
40 million at Netflix sarando's 38
million at Netflix Brian Roberts Comcast
CEO 30
million they're doing hey they're doing
well they're doing well and
I understand the writers going we want
more
because they're getting they're getting
a lot of money they're making a lot of
money the discovery CEO this guy David
zazlev 250 million last year he did well
how did he make that much money what
happened over there
who even watches discovery
there's got to be something else he's
got to have something else going on
is he Warner he's Warner Brothers too
right Discovery CEO David says love what
does he do
can't just be discovery
yeah he was oh it's Warner Bros
Discovery yeah yeah well that yeah of
course okay
he's the CEO Warner Brothers and all
these writers are mad and I get it and
Adam Conover is going why does he have
the money and I don't I did the the show
where I talk about people's water
I understand that he's because I talk I
do the show where I talk about where
people's water comes from and that's
good
but he's gonna have a little more than
you but I think Conover should be given
more money for this show he did about
um
what it was the Adam ruins everything
where he'd go in and somebody would go I
think uh I don't know what that he would
like expose things he'd be like the
suburbs are racist and people would be
like
okay and then he would talk to tell you
how
and that's fun
that's fun and it's funny
it's funny and it's fun
and that's the type of programming
people will pay to see that's what I pay
to see when I'm sitting at home after a
long day I want to know about how racist
the suburbs are that makes that's fun
get the family gather around this is
great content
um
so hey I want them all to make money
these writers I do I do I do I do I do
and it's not you know this is I know
that I'm being satirical here but I
really
I want them I want everyone to be okay
[Music]
but David's as love is more productive
than many of you because I know some of
you
I know some of you and I think the CEO
of Warner Brothers is probably more
productive than you
okay
what if they got tough
what if like zazloving these guys
started getting tough and going like
let's send people down to the picket
lines with bats
you know
wouldn't this be crazy if a god like
that it would be nuts
would be entertaining no one cares less
about this strike than America but they
should
because shows like Outer Banks which is
about uh people in uh
North Carolina
that are kind of like
hot Pirates
but it's a show about
it's like Beverly Hills 902-0 but
they're poor and they live in North
Carolina
someone's writing that some some genius
some Geniuses writing that so I'm just
saying you you you're barking up the
wrong artificial intelligence tree
because Chad gbt might be able to do
that they might be able to ride Outer
Banks you have no idea they might they
might give you an outer Bank script
can you get an outer Bank script up
right now I'm just going to see if chat
GPT can do it I bet they can do it Outer
Banks was one of the biggest shows on
Netflix it is a tremendously popular
show uh with uh the young demo The Taste
cluster just like Wednesday or any of
these other shows that are atrocious
now
is this Outer Banks this is the pilot
yeah okay this is the pilot
it won't work if you don't apply
yourself
okay so here's what's happening a
teenage kid stands with his heels over
the edge of a balcony without a railing
behind him we see the curve of the
coastline Moonlight on the dark ocean
the kid is holding a beer can wearing a
t-shirt that reads Bad Brains
a neck Gator around his head gives him a
surfy
Unabomber vibe
this is John B a combo plate of Lloyd
dobler Ferris Bueller and Matt Dillon
from The Outsiders two parts eccentric
non-conformist one part Angry Young Man
I'm in already
it won't work if you don't apply
yourself it's like all that went to the
same pep talk training camp a friend
Pope 16 African-American love child of
Mr Spock and a deadpan comedian watches
laconically if you fall you have a 12
and a half percent chance of living John
B then I won't fall and I am applying
myself just not the way they want
boom
can Chachi PT do this
can chat GPT do this
because if it can
you're all in the street
you're all going to be in the street now
I don't want you to be in the street I
want them to pay you fairly that's why I
was with David zazlov last night we were
at the Beverly Hills Hotel and he goes
can we use a non-lethal gas on them I
said David yes but absolutely he goes
because I don't like seeing them outside
my office and I go absolutely I go but
but but David
let's think about this for a second he
was non-lethal I go I understand that he
goes just disorient them
and then I called read hey I texted read
Hastings I said me and David are
thinking about a non-lethal disorienting
gas and he goes LOL and he was with Ted
and he goes lol Having exact same convo
right now
they were at Craig's we all meet up
and we start talking about different
types of gas
David knows someone in the CIA who can
get us the gas
this is what we're thinking about doing
now now
this isn't right but this is the ideas
that we have right now or it's a
non-lethal gas that will disorient them
and will make them seem crazy and scary
to the general public thereby making all
of their all their prop it's a big
propaganda win for the billionaires if
we can disorient the writers and make
them seem like drug addicts and lunatics
this is why during the 1960s when the
anti-war movement was mainly led by
priests and like kind of respectable
members of society the CIA was like we
need these people on acid immediately
all of a sudden all these people started
doing acid they were running around
naked uh you know jumping in uh mud
puddles and America went wait they're
against the war the war must be good
Vietnam must be good these crazy people
are against it so what we're trying to
do and again not me but I'm just friend
these are my friends I don't ditch my
friends and like we were talking you
know what I mean
and
so what we're trying to do right now is
introduce kind of a poison that would
spread by touching because many of them
are touching each other
and it would disorient it would make
them behave erratically because if they
can start behaving erratically
at these things but I I I don't know
what I'm gonna do without my Saturday
Night Live
do you America
pay them more
um
what else were we talking about the
other day that made me laugh I love I
love everyone in the writer's room by
the way and I want you know everybody
everybody is
everybody's A-Okay with me I love
bespoke posts because they have the box
of Awesome
every month it sneaks up on you because
you forget it's coming and then one day
boom on your front door the best box
you'll open all month it's filled with
carefully chosen gear from the best
small Brands around the world let's see
what I got this month oh no it's so cool
to get started take the quiz at
boxofawesome.com because here's what it
is folks you take a quiz in the box of
awesome knows exactly what to put in
this little box each box is valued at
around 70 but you only pay a fraction of
that price okay
I took a quiz and I got a box of awesome
box and everything in it was exactly
what I wanted I loved it and I told my
friends and family about it we all
started crying about how beautiful it
was plus with box of awesome you're
supporting small businesses ninety
percent of everything that comes in your
box of awesome is from a small up and
coming brand this is great for people
that are moving cities going to college
going away whoever it is you're giving
them a gift but you're really giving
them 12 gifts getting 20 off your first
monthly box when you sign up at box of
awesome.com and enter the code Tim
Dillon to check out that's box of
awesome.com
20 off your first box box of awesome.com
code Tim Dillon I want to talk about
this because Whole Foods is having a
real problem here in
San Francisco
Tech workers have stayed home this is in
the New York Times ongoing social
problems downtown are forcing Civic and
Business Leaders to confront harsh
realities about the pandemic recovery
what's happening right now in Whole
Foods from what I understand
is
this is what's going on in Whole Foods
guns knives and sticks
they fling food
screamed fought tried to defecate on the
floor
these are the homeless
so the homeless have taken over a Whole
Foods in downtown San Francisco
many of the good people there the good
tech people the progressive good people
are trying to go in and to get their
kale Caesar salad and such
and instead they're confronted with the
reality of someone defecating which
means [__] on the floor and flinging
food and maybe flinging excrement at
them
and then they have to go home and go I
just left Whole Foods and I'm covered in
[__] which nobody wants to say that
when Whole Foods opened it was supposed
to be for the white that's who it was
for let's cut it out it was for the
white
let's be honest
kind of like nerdy hipstery Progressive
liberal organic food eating vegan
socially conscious environmentally sound
perfect human right
they're saying that I'm not saying
now those people
they're being disturbed by bleeding
homeless sores
vagrancy disgusting the smell of Rotting
Flesh
in all Foods in San Francisco
here are some of the reports
that 911 has gotten
Mel with machete is back
another security guard was just
assaulted
a man with a four inch knife attacks
several security guards then sprayed
store employees with foam from a fire
extinguisher
in September a 30 year old man died in
the bathroom from an overdose of
fentanyl a highly potent opioid and
methamphetamine
this does not sound like a good place to
get groceries it sounds like an insane
asylum
but is this just the price you pay
for being a good person
if you're a good part shouldn't you walk
into a place like this
and take a look at everything going on
around you and go
this is just the price of me being a
good guy I'm a good person and if I get
stabbed or if I have to walk over a dead
body on the way to get uh some quinoa is
that the biggest deal is it such a big
deal
I don't know I don't know if it's such a
big deal
I think this is just the way the world
is going to go there are going to be
people that mind this and people that
don't
there are going to be people that now
I'm going to be honest I'm not perfect
I'm mind I mind the blood and the guts
and the killing I don't like it
I can't get with it but many people
I'm sure there are comments on this
article there are people that are going
to say so what everyone has a bad day
so what he showed up with a machete he's
just trying to protect himself from the
cops they're the real problem
not the man with the machete
people overdose it's sad people are
gonna go it's sad that someone's
overdosing in the bathroom it's actually
sad
it's actually very sad that's what it is
let's do nothing about it
let's do nothing about it except
recognize how tragic and sad it is
and then let more of it happen but we
can't do anything it's sad it's
unfortunate it's sad it's regrettable
it shouldn't happen but it does and it
will and we can do nothing but stand by
and walk over the bodies walk over the
corpse on your way to get a smoothie
so now Whole Foods are supposed to cater
to the workers and other Professionals
of the attack of the city's Tech of
course of course we know who are you
telling me Whole Foods wasn't set up for
guys with machetes
are you telling me that people on
fentanyl aren't really looking at the
organic food options and all foods yeah
this was set up for the people that are
fleeing San Francisco in droves
this is the problem and this guy
tragically died on the New York City
subway this guy Jordan Neely he was a
Michael Jackson impersonator and he was
yelling at everyone on the train and
then the Marine choked him and killed
him now I don't know the specifics of
this and you know we don't want anyone
to die right but the problem is when you
have violent uh mental patients running
around cities screaming in people's
faces you're going to get you're going
to have altercations and then the result
of some of those altercations inevitably
is going to be that people are going to
die or get maimed or get hurt okay okay
I have to talk to everyone like they're
five okay sit Indian style around and
I'm going to tell you why it's not a
good idea to have violent Psychopaths
running around the city okay everyone
and then we'll have nap
but it's not a good idea because people
are going to take things into their own
hands
see like the Marine who choked the guy
to death
people do that because people feel like
well hey cops aren't figuring it out
guys on here being a lunatic was it
Justified I don't know what the guy was
doing
I'm saying at the end of the day I have
a [__] cold again everyone's gonna go
he's on coke see I did I got it to Whole
Foods
but the reality is
this is why you cannot have Anarchy and
Chaos in the streets this is why now
losers fetishize Anarchy and Chaos
because it's it they so hate
civilization
that anything that's destroying
civilization isn't is a good
so somebody taking a [__] in the Whole
Foods buffet or a Michael Jackson
impersonator screaming at everyone's
face in the train or any lunatic at all
guy with machete whoever they're all
they're all forces for good because
there's a lot of people that hate
civilization and want it to end
immediately
so for those people there is no reason
with them you can't talk to them you
can't explain it to them those are the
people who say when the Whole Foods
article comes out they go so what
so what just a couple of security guards
that got stabbed
you know and you you can't explain it to
them we've got to figure out something
to do with these violent Psychopaths
they should start writing for television
and streaming 100 their ideas are better
they've had more life experience than
these writers and they will not strike
I'm telling you David says love listen
to me start hiring put one homeless
psychopath in every writer's room
thing they want give them everything
they want on that [__] contract and
then say and we got another one you know
how you want to employ people and defund
the police and well here's how we do
that we're going to put one homeless
drug addicted psychopath in every
writer's room and you guys are gonna
deal with it you are going to deal with
it and I bet they'll have great ideas
and I bet they'll be interesting they
might not always be appropriate they
might not know
they might not address Everyone by the
correct pronoun but I will say
you dig a guy with a machete out of
Whole Foods and you have him right for
La Brea that show's getting better
that shows getting 150 percent better
because he's gonna be like this isn't
this doesn't feel like real life
nobody's [__] on the street
Bluetooth if you want a harder dick you
got to go to Bluetooth it makes a lot of
sense everybody loves it everybody needs
it
Bluetooth unique online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
Viagra Cialis and leviche but in
chewable tablets at a fraction of the
cost you can take them anytime day or
night you can plan ahead be ready
whenever an opportunity arises the
process is simple sign of bluetooth.com
consult with one of their licensed
medical providers and once you're
approved you'll receive your
prescription within days the best part
it's well done online so no visits to
the doctor's office no awkward
conversations and no waiting in line at
the pharmacy Bluetooth tablets are made
in the USA and prepared and shipped
directly to your door in a discreet
package it works everybody loves it
everybody needs it it's something you
can share uh with your family and show
them your penis and say look at this
hard gank and everybody starts clapping
and they applaud and they gotta look at
our boy go
we've got a special deal for our
listeners try Bluetooth free when you
use a promo code TD at checkout that you
just pay five dollars shipping
bluetooth.com promo code TD to receive
your first month free bluetooth.com for
more details and important safety
information and we thank Bluetooth for
sponsoring the podcast I'll tell you
this
um I'm a little I'm a little you know we
we this is so predictable
that this would happen
um unfortunately it's very predictable
that these types of things happen
uh US Navy hires an active duty drag
queen to be the face of recruitment
drive this is a good idea
this is a great idea because
number one
anyone joining the military right now
I mean come on at this point
haven't you figured out a better way to
get your college paid for than this and
college now is fake it does nothing for
anyone going I went to college in the
military period it doesn't even matter
anymore right so the the joining the
military now and I'll let respect to
those who do it we need a military but
many of the people who are joining it
right now are let's can we say they're
out of options
not all of them
but some of them they're completely out
of options okay
um and and it's it's obvious because the
military is not hitting their
recruitment goals meaning that the milk
people aren't joint people don't want it
they don't want it they don't want to go
to the Ukraine they don't want to fight
in Sudan they don't want it they don't
they they go this doesn't feel like uh
you know something that I want to be a
part of anymore
so in order to entice people back into
the military
um the U.S Navy hired an active duty
drag queen to be the face of the
recruitment tribes because we should
you know drag queens a lot of them are
strapping men they're tall they're broad
shoulder they're big they're muscular
get them in there
get them in there get them in there
let's have an army of drag queens
they're in better shape most Americans
are fat they're lazy they don't want to
join the Navy they're not
it's some fat guy in Ohio he used to
play football it's Al Bundy all of them
get muscular drag queens
recruit them that's who you need can we
watch this yep
so this is one of their tick tocks
[Music]
I don't have any problem with this but
this may not be the most effective way
to get people in there but maybe it is
uh
maybe it is
who's joining the Navy
who is Joe who is excited to join the
Navy
[Music]
okay all right
um I don't know who's joining the Navy I
don't know why anyone would join the
military right now I mean I know that
it's you like whatever
I know that we need a military and I get
that people love the country and want to
but is that why people
join it but like I I just I don't
understand like maybe you need to get
this is a way to get drag queens into
the Navy because I'm not joining the I
don't know anyone who's joining the Navy
so you're gonna fight for Taiwan in six
months
I'm not saying that's a bad thing
but listen let that's what's about to
happen you know it's not enticing that's
not exciting now the drag queen going
we're gonna have fun we're gonna [__]
cut up you can dress like anything you
want you know I mean maybe that's the
best way to go here maybe maybe it's
like oh the military's too woke maybe
it's not woke enough
maybe it's not woke enough maybe you
need all these woke people in the
military maybe you need uh to make the
military like appealing to other groups
of people it's not appealing to most
people I know to be honest with you most
people I know are not looking to join
right now they're not you know
we've been told too many lies about
these wars and what these wars mean and
why we're fighting them and I think a
lot of people are under the impression
that these wars benefit a very small
group of people that make a lot of money
from them but they're not really vital
to our national security and vital to
our national interests so I think that's
why a lot of people go I'm going to work
at Panera instead and I'll get soup
when the [__] comes in with the minivan
full of kids and she goes excuse me
and I'll get her the soup I'll get her
the apples slices for the kids I'll get
her a little bread I'll get her the
thing because I don't want to fight a
war and die
um so that people can make more money
that doesn't now obviously we need a
military but this is why you can't lie
to them right this is why you can't put
them in unwinnable situations this is
why you can't give them [__] [__]
health coverage when they come back home
this is why you can't you know ignore a
suicide crisis amongst the military and
maybe
those military members that are killing
themselves when they get home or doing
it because they're all trance
we haven't thought of that
maybe the whole military is trans anyway
and when they come home from these wars
they kill themselves not because of the
horrors that they witnessed overseas at
War maybe it's because they have not
been given access to trans affirming
care
we might have a trans military already
most of the people in America I know
someone in the military that's kind of
trans
I'm not going to go into more of that
I'm just saying
people get into weird [__] people get in
and not the trans is weird [__] but
people get into interesting [__] when
they spend a lot of time overseas in
different cultures people get to get
into very interesting stuff so
I don't think this is necessarily a bad
idea to just try to recruit uh people
that uh have interesting weird fetishes
I would go after and I'm not equating
this with drag queens but I'm saying I
would go after furries
why is he not a furry who's like I
joined the military and I'm [__] they
call me uh fly fox or whatever you know
why not have a furry why not have you
know like why not go after people that
are a little different and try to get
them into the military because
really is that I mean what's the hook
now right it always was get the college
paid for forever but now no one cares
about colleges right so what's the hook
now
fight for your freedom No One Believes
that but if people go I can be dragged
in the military and get to and have a
gun and get to kill people that's pretty
cool
I'm a killer Dre I'm a drag queen that
kills
I slay but lit literally slay like I
slay for real I slay children
I slay brown kids that pissed us off
why not that's a good idea
that's what the military should be
because the military is not going to be
mainstream people right now
life is too good here people aren't
joining the [__] military they're
going at their [__] postmating Sushi
and playing guitar or whatever the hell
you do like people
they're not gonna do it so you got to go
to people that have had it hard drag
queens have had it hard they've taken
some abuse they've taken some [__] our
military should we should be Biden
should get out and have the balls to say
in five years we want an all-drag
military
we want to begin the transition to a
permanent drag military
because they've dealt with [__] and
they've had it hard you know
it should be the military should be in
cells it should be drag queens it should
be people that have been through [__]
people that are on the margins of
society people that can be used as
cannon fodder for the wars of the rich
which is what it's becoming I'm not
saying it's a volunteer Force so don't
get mad at me but if you can be used as
cannon fodder
for the rich if they decide like we need
to get into Israel by John why shut up
Freedom you go over there you get your
head blown off and then everybody buys a
boat
joking this mother lied about being
kidnapped as Q Anon mom the Republican
Party by the way is Q anon's back with
them look at her eyes look at the eyes
of this woman
here's the deal cute's back because it's
a lot easier than understanding like you
know uh economic debates or monetary
policy there's 20 percent of the
Republican party that uh and maybe 20
percent of the country in general that
remains schizophrenic
um they're unable to decipher what is
real and what is fake that'll only be
made worse by chat GPT by AI by Deep
fakes things like that we will get to a
point in this country where nobody
really knows what's going on ever what's
real what's fake everything will be uh
some type of fantasy many people are
already living in a fantasy land uh a
lot of them are on the right A lot of
people on the left also live in a
fantasy land but they live in different
kinds of fantasy lands but the Q Anon
thing where you take a real premise like
human trafficking and a real premise
like political corruption that do exist
and they have been related before but
you use that as this catch-all
conspiracy literally to draw lines
between everything and everyone that's
ever existed and everybody that's ever
succeeded and anyone that's ever done
anything uh good anyone that has any
money anyone that has any power and you
say that they're all pedophiles and that
Donald Trump is fighting a secret shadow
War to get rid of them and those people
are have all been executed they're all
Guantanamo Bay
all of these things are um crazy right
and we know that they're crazy and
they've been exposed as crazy right
um but that doesn't matter because
people are they they will not let this
go they will not let the Q Anon idea go
because politics is supposed to be
boring
it's people fighting about like how much
money should go to the water [__]
treatment plant that's not fun and the
people that are really into politics
specifically on Twitter are too stupid
to understand
what the slow grinding Gears of this
bloated dying corpse of an Empire how
they actually work that would take
reading and stuff what they do like and
what is fun is pretending you're freeing
children from underground prisons that's
fun if you're gonna look at Politics as
a hobby reading books about how the you
know whatever you want to call it how
this oligarchy managerial stayed as
Bannon would say or whatever these deep
State Nexus of Institutions these power
factions reading about the lobbyists the
congressmen the Senators how they all
influence each other how the executive
branch
um functions within the government how
things get done how susceptible all
these people are to all kinds of
different uh influence is including
blackmail and things like that but this
is very difficult to understand on a
macro level on a big level but what's
easy to understand is we should free the
kids from the underground cages which is
the simplest
uh and this is what people understand
this is what the Q Anon faction
understands it cannot understand
politics they do not they do not want to
it is not in there they don't have the
ability to what they have the ability to
believe is that there are kids in
underground there probably are kids in
underground cages but they these people
are not freeing them Donald Trump is not
freeing them Donald Trump's concern is
Donald Trump there's no kids got freed
um
so a wannabe Bay Area mom influencer who
sparked panic among Q Anon Believers
with a trumped-up story about the
attempted kidnapping of her children has
been found guilty of lying to law
enforcement
Katie swords in 31 win Final in 2020
when she posted a series of videos to
her Instagram account she claimed that
on December 7th 2020 she took her two
small children to the Michael's craft
store in Petaluma
while in the store
there's nothing better
than making up that your kids are
kidnapped there's nothing funnier
there's nothing better than a mother
making up a story that her children were
kidnapped there's nothing more fun
while in the store she alleged a man and
woman began to follow her talking about
the features of my children so now
imagine how creepy this is
you're walking around the Michael's Arts
and Crafts in Petaluma and then a man
and a woman
I don't know who they are in This
Woman's head I guess let's just call
them Barack and Michelle Obama
are following her around saying her kids
are hot
Sorensen said the couple didn't buy
anything but followed her out to the
parking lot she accused them of taking
quote two steps forward two steps back
before lunging for her stroller
Sorensen said she called for help talked
to the police and then decided to share
her story on social media to warn other
parents
my children were the target of an
attempted kidnap
sitting in her car which is such a weird
thing even vocalize but it happened and
I want to share the story with you
the videos accrued more than 4 million
views before Sorensen made her account
private soon investigator said it was
clear Sorenson's account wasn't meshing
with the evidence
security footage
from the Michaels did not corroborate
her story said Petaluma Police
there are many inconsistencies when she
retold the story they soon cleared the
couple
Sadie and Eddie Martinez have any
wrongdoing Sorensen meanwhile took to
local TV to repeat her story I saw these
people they didn't look necessarily
clean cut she said on on KTVU I felt
uncomfortable around them last week
Jordan guilty of making a false report
of a crime to a detective prosecutors
say she faces up to six months in prison
for the misdemeanor but she was taken
into custody after the verdict and held
on a hundred thousand dollars bail
she moved out of state after the
incident before her internet infamy
Sorensen was a self-described
independent Wellness Advocate Hawking
essential oils and this is the Q Anon
and the wellness people
are very similar there's a lot of
concentric circles between the Q Anon uh
they're trying to kidnap my kids and
Michaels
which isn't true
and the Wellness Community of the
essential oils
it's a multi-level marketing company so
she was part of this multi-level
marketing scam it's like a Mary Kay
cosmetics but she's slinging essential
oils to other white women whose kids are
being Q Anand
it's interesting it's just funny to me
the idea that a mother which by the way
it's got to be the most terrifying thing
in the world to have your kids kidnapped
as a mother or attempted an attempted
kidnapping has got to be as a mother
the most terrifying thing just the idea
that it could happen is terrifying just
the idea that it could take place it's
got to be the most rattling thing if
you're a mother so the idea that this
woman would not only make it up she made
it up
but then went out and terrified other
people and said they're coming for your
kids now I'm telling you they came from
mine
this sick [__]
wanted attention so bad because that's
what we have left in this country is
attention
she wanted it so badly that she made a
story up that people lunged for her baby
stroller in the Michaels Crafts parking
lot
that they lunged for the stroller so
this is the problem
uh with the Q Anon schizophrenics
is that it's it's they're inventing
stories because reality has not been
kind to them no one's in jail no one
went to Guantanamo
Hillary's still walking around she's fat
now but she's not in jail
the Obamas all the people they said were
going to be in jail at Guantanamo Bay it
never happened
none of this ever happened
all of this stuff the react so they have
to now invent things that help them with
their world view they have to go like oh
well you know they were trying they
weren't Michael's crafts
and they lunge at my stroller and now
this [__] is going to
jail
Ruth Chris one of my least favorite
restaurants in the world was recently
bought by Darden Restaurant Group
Olive Garden owner Darden Restaurants
buys Ruth Chris Steakhouse for
715 million
Ruth Chris is one of the lower end
corporate steakhouses in America I mean
if you are in Grand Rapids Michigan
isn't that where we ate there yes
yes if you have to eat there it's it's
not the worst thing in the world but
Ruth Chris is not a good restaurant
it's not good it's for uh teachers
Ruth Chris is a place for you know it's
for
it's for people that shouldn't be at a
steakhouse
that's what Ruth Chris says it's for
people that shouldn't be at a steakhouse
it's for people who you know how many
people I've watched it Ruth Chris argue
about a birthday promotion
it's that type of restaurant where they
go okay and also it's my birthday
also that's how you know you're in a
nice restaurant when someone goes okay I
know the checks here but uh
also well it's my birthday or the best
one it's her birthday
so I know we have to settle up with you
but is there any way we can knock some
money off this because I was born today
it's my birthday
if I go to a restaurant my birthday I
just go shh don't please right but
there's a lot of people out there that
are just trying to you know get Ruth
Chris
for all the money that it can be so it's
I you know I've seen you know so so
I don't know what they're gonna do at
Ruth Chris are there any plans are they
going to make it better
are they going to make it more
interesting
seems like they just acquired it and
they're not really releasing any plans
there's nothing to do
there's nothing to do with Ruth Chris
the same type I've ever eaten Ruth Chris
because I tour around the country as a
comedian and a lot of these towns Ruth
Chris is the only thing out there and
it's the only thing open
but it's far below a Capital Grill a
Smith and malinsky's and Del Frisco's
and Ocean Prime Ruth Chris is like the
entry level Steakhouse
you know it's it's just for people that
could just got out of jail
it's like a got out of jail meal it's
like one of the first meals you have
when you gotta get out of jail
like your family picks you up and goes
let's go to Ruth Chris because you're
out of jail that and also tell them it's
your birthday
we're gonna tell him it's your brother I
know you just got out of jail for uh
battery
but it's time to eat some mashed
potatoes and then tell them it's your
birthday so we can save a little money
that's what Ruth Chris is you know Ruth
Chris is not uh
it's not something you don't really feel
special being in a Ruth Chris you're
like huh
what is the story of Ruth Chris how did
it start is Ruth Chris an actual person
I don't know anything about it other
than the fact that it's like
incredibly
not that impressive it was found in 1927
by New Orleans entrepreneur
Chris baluch
to start in New Orleans
Ruth fertel was a divorced single mother
who needed money to send her teenage
Sons to college
of course and that's who's still eating
there
divorced single mothers but that's what
it means right ignoring the advice of
her Banker lawyer and Friends Ruth
purchased a restaurant 1965 and then you
know blah blah blah became really
successful
but you know when I just read that it
was started by a divorced single mother
it all makes sense to me because it very
much is a divorced single mother
restaurant
people with like martinis at the bar
that are like blue
you know the martinis the color of like
the thing they put combs in in the
barber shop yeah the barber side and the
drinking those and they're like Ugh and
they're just waiting for
some man to come in there with Deep
Pockets but the only people are eating
in that restaurant are con artists who
are trying to take you for your money
because you're at [__] Ruth Chris
they're gonna steal your credit card
Ruth Chris is repulsive
but I do wish and Darden what does
Darden own Darden owns a bunch of
restaurants that are also repulsive
yeah it's like almost all of them
they're all bad it's Olive Garden Olive
Garden's rough LongHorn Steakhouse
cheddar scratch kitchen Yard House I do
like Yard House
um
I do like Yard House
Capital Grill I like a lot
Seasons 52 no Bahama Breeze no Eddie V's
Prime Seafood yeah not really
but I do like Capital Grille so Darden
does have
some brands that are okay your house is
decent Yard House is like in a big
California mall it's like a massive
place where people can go get like beers
you can get like an onion ring Tower and
you can get like
you know tuna tartare wontons or
something it's like that type of
restaurant you go you get like tuna
tartar nachos
you get like a um yeah there it is pull
that up make that big right there make
that big that's what yard house is make
it big make it bigger I want to see it
big
this is your house but what is this it's
the video hold on I don't want the video
we don't want the video I just want to
see see that's what yard house is
there's a woman there she's got a
massive uh beer she's got some type of
dip in front of her and she's got I
guess make it smaller so we can see the
onion rings
she's got a tower of onion rings
because that's what your yard house is
for people that when you put onion rings
and Tower they go oh yeah
that's that's what yard house is for
it's for when the onion rings
hit the table and they're in a tower it
makes someone's day
and make someone's day and then they
just have things on the menu for no
reason they'll have like garlic shiitake
garlic noodles
look at you fancy pants you're having
shiitake garlic noodles it's 111 degrees
out you're in Palm Desert California
you're in the yard house and you're
eating shiitake garlic noodles
and thinking about how much money it's
gonna cost for your divorce how cool is
that
Yard House is for people who who've just
been denied alone
that's where you go after you've just
been denied alone and you're like well I
can still eat good here
it's when your bank calls you and goes
there's nothing really we can do
at this point taking a new account like
you can hear the bank saying it as they
wait on the line like you can like you
can hear like the bank being like taking
into account the income and the credit
they're like two two please yeah yeah
what what so taking into account the
income and the credit we're not able to
proceed with the car loan of six
thousand dollars they go all right all
right I understand [__] all right well
I'm gonna have to onion ring Tower and
the tuna tartar uh the Tuna the Tuna
spicy tuna whatever you put that on what
do you put it on a pizza just bring it
to the table give me a big uh cold beer
and a fat Hispanic woman if you can't
just bring out a fat Hispanic woman with
two children a cold beer and then a
tower of onion rings if you can because
but I like yard house because I like it
knows what it is there's certain
restaurants that know what they are
they're like let's make the food into
gimmicks because the people that eat
here don't have much like and they're
not here's the other thing Yard House
the people that eat in Yard House are
not broke it's not like Popeyes in a bad
area it's like Yard House so what it is
people who are playing this game of
America they're in the game
but it's not great
the ball's hitting them
they're not reacting that's what yard
house is for people that are in the game
people that are trying to sell a 2019
Chevy Silverado
hmm
because they need something
are eating at yard house that's who eats
at Yard House people that are in the
game they're not
totally destitute they're not living on
the street they're not an intent they're
not unfental they're not [__] in a
Whole Foods
but they're trying to make very small
moves
to better themselves
and they're doing it at a yard house
because that's a place they can let
loose
have a couple of beers watch the game
and think about how
they're going to come up with the money
to euthanize their dog
because that's what that restaurant's
about it's about figuring out how to
move money around so you have enough
money to put your dog down
Yard House
get the menu up and you are and I can I
can prove this when you read the menu
you go this is where I would go and I
like by the way I like Yard House many
times in my life I've been a Yard House
person
I've gone to Yard House go to the
appetizers
appetizers coconut shrimp
onion ring Tower
jumbo Bavarian pretzel
this is a study of what people in this
country will eat the lower middle class
grilled Korean barbecue beef
Wisconsin fried cheese curds
avocado toast calamari there's no theme
to Yard House by the way
the theme of the foodie Yard House is
anything you've heard of
anything you've heard of and nothing you
haven't sweet potato fries snacks I like
that they have an appetizer section and
a snack section because it's like you
might want to snack in between the
appetizer and the entree
Stacks guacamole truffle fries sweet
potato fries edamame shiitake garlic
noodles who doesn't want a big bowl of
garlic noodles as a snack these are just
Foods you've heard of that's what yard
house is it's Foods you've already heard
of but they're here in the mall
We're Not educated it's not like would
you like some Arctic char what no it's
would you and what is this Garden
everything there's gardein with a little
r Garden Wings Garden orange chicken
pizzas they got pizza too they have
something called The Vampire
a cheese
curated tortilla Carnitas bacon roasted
garlic crushed avocado none of it makes
sense
sour cream cilantro it's just things
you've heard of
things you've heard of on a plate come
to Yard House we won't challenge you
you like noodles
you'll get noodles so what is this
Garden it says it's a chicken substitute
made from soy wheat oh nice
meatless
but I like yarn I like yard house I'll
go to Yard House right [__] now
and I'll talk to a divorced substitute
teacher
whose son is severely autistic and she
wants a white zinfandel and she needs an
onion ring Tower
stat
because her husband became trans and
joined the military
Yard House is just a collection of
simple tragedies at the yard house it's
not even it's people that you can't
really feel bad for either when they
start talking you go oh
can't really feel bad for you kind of a
terrible person you're dumb
but it's like the Yard House when people
start telling you the problems you're
like oh you've gone further than you
should have you've gone it'll be some
guy who's like I invested with my
brother
in a company that turned out not to have
existed and and then like he'll start
screaming like five minutes in about
like the border and I was like and it's
the [__] border they're coming over
here
you lost all your money with your
brother you idiot I was like yeah
whatever can I have some carne asada
garlic noodles I don't know what it is
but I've heard of it can I have a
Bavarian pencil and an avocado toast
they have avocado toast can I have a
Bavarian avocado toast pretzel please
and some [__] Korean beef
I want some Korean beef and a vampire
I hope this is played
at every Yard House every worker at a
Yard House
every Yard House worker because it's
like sometimes attractive women kind of
um
people that are excited like a few of
them have said oh where fans of your
work so
I appreciate that but you get what I'm
saying here you understand what I'm
saying Yard House Foods you've heard of
you're in a mall anyway you're here
anyway Yard House basically like you're
in a mall anyway these are foods you've
heard of you cannot afford your children
you cannot afford your children come to
your house have get your children a
pizza and sit there and think about how
you're going to get yourself under get
yourself out from under this mountain of
debt and horrible decisions that you've
made in this disgusting restaurant where
you're just eating fat and sugar you get
in your car you have a headache you're
like I'm full in a weird way I don't
feel good I'm having a panic attack
should I go to the hospital no can't
afford that just keep driving just keep
driving with your your face covered with
Yard House glaze whatever [__] sick
disgusting sugar glaze they toss
everything in you're just like oh
you go back to your house
they can barely afford you put the kids
in front of the TV they're all on drugs
they're all trans you're happy about it
you don't care
you're trying to get money from the
government you go can I get money from
the government if they're trans your
wife goes shut up
you go to Yard House
did you go to Yard House again stop
trying to make our kids trans get money
from the government did you have a
Bavarian pretzel at noon you sick [__]
[Laughter]
it's a disgusting place but I like it
timelacomedy.com we're in Palm Beach all
weekend we've got tickets available from
San Francisco they're available lots of
them lots of them
Chicago Theater very few
um
Milwaukee Wisconsin the Pabst Theater
tickets are available funner California
that uh Harrah's Resort Casino that's
available uh Bensalem Pennsylvania
that's in September who cares but still
go
uh Tim dilloncomedy.com if you want any
live uh tickets and we'll hang out I'm
so excited to be going to Palm Beach
baby good night goodbye and watch the
episode of those two dudes they're
[__] they're awesome dudes and uh
we're starting a boy band peace